after surviving breast cancer our next
guest has made it her mission
to make major strides literally
in raising money and awareness to fight
this horrible disease
cheryl kohlberg is running 50 miles
for 50 days in 50 states
all in the name of finding a cure and
cheryl joins me now hi cheryl
hi drew hi thank you so much for having
me i'm so happy to be here
oh cheryl we really wanted to make a
whole segment out of this because
i was blown away by your story
so much so there's just a lot to talk
about
how are you feeling now what's your
latest diagnosis how is everything
i'm doing great i've been cancer-free
since last december
feeling great having life yeah
living every day to the moment so it's
awesome oh
that's so wonderful you really are an
inspiration in every single
aspect of life health and wellness
mental space
philanthropy and what sort of was the
running piece of the puzzle what made
that click for you
well i've always been a runner and when
i was going through
treatment there were days when i
literally could not even get out of bed
so for me it was really important to get
back to running to make me feel
normal again and it's a great way to get
people
involved and promote breast cancer
awareness
and give people hope so it's been great
i love running and
it's a great way to get out get exercise
mental health physical health
it's all good i will say that you have
truly
incentivized here um sometimes
you know we don't really know how to get
involved and
the way that you've presented your
website and the challenge i
scoured through it i i am very excited
to to try to join you on this but first
i have a very exciting announcement
i would like to introduce someone to you
um
and um so we all think what you're doing
here is just
so important and this is jill from none
other than
get ready for this bank of america
drop the mic jill
thank you so much for coming on the show
why is it important for you to be here
today
thank you drew thank you for having me
it's so great to be here and
cheryl my colleagues and i at bank of
america
have been following your story and we're
so
impressed by all the work that you're
doing and the commitment that you've
made to raise awareness
around breast cancer and give so much
hope to so many so
to thank you for running 50 miles in 50
days
with partners across 50 states
in your honor we're going to donate 50
000 to susan g komen
are you serious that's amazing thank you
so
much you're gonna help save so many
lives that is
amazing you know what i can't thank you
enough actually that's not all
jill no is there something else what
there's just
there's just one more thing i mean this
year has just been
so unprecedented in so many ways
and your story is even more inspiring
and in the hopes that one day no one has
to face a breast cancer diagnosis alone
so in celebration of your 50th birthday
milestone
we're gonna donate another fifty
thousand dollars for a total of a
hundred thousand dollars
a hundred thousand dollars oh
thank you so much that means so much to
me
and for all those women that are
battling this terrible disease
you're gonna help find a cure thank you
so much and jill
i cannot thank you enough for this
incredible opportunity you are our hero
and cheryl you have inspired me i'm
going to post the website on our site
i'm joining you i'm going to try to run
the mile
by october 31st october is breast cancer
awareness month
and so in honor of you our pod our squad
is going to start the mission we're
going to start a facebook group
and we want to do this with you i've
never run a mile in my life i'm so
excited
everybody get involved
[Music]
you